hello everybody how are you sorry baby
came here a bit later today but I was
shooting for some data I'll be fighting
for the consumer confidence that came at
101.3 it fell koala to be honest the
expected was a hundred for the one and
if we check what they actually said
let's come here
here the expectation index based on
consumer short-term outlook for income
business and labor market conditions
fell to 6801
from 74. the expectation index has now
remained below 80 the level associated
with a recession within the next year
okay I have basically telling you that
consumers became more pessimistic about
the outlook for both business conditions
and labor markets
so basically telling you that a consumer
is worried
and under respecting adaptation and how
can they not
if everybody is calling foreign
so this is normal
so you are telling me that a consumer
confidence has dropped that their
respect in a recession that they are
getting quite pessimistic and worried
about their jobs the labor market and
the economy in the short term but at the
same time there is something that is not
matching here and is that the new home
sales is the data that just came into
right now
yes came in very hot
000 new houses have been sold during the
last month okay compared to the previous
one so you know how is that possible is
it because
they are getting used to high interest
rates the the consumers the consumer
spending hasn't slowed down I'm gonna
post a chart I'll try to post a thread
later today on on Twitter but they're
going to be able to see that the
consumer spending has not stopped
delegating used to high inflation High
interest rates and that's indeed a
problem because when you buy a house
unless if you are a cash buyer don't
need a mortgage with high interest rates
you want to pay a lot of money to the
bank because now it's expensive to get a
loan to get a mortgage they're gonna
have to buy fewer actually don't have to
go shopping
so this is
fueling inflation this is gonna be a
problem for the FED how is the Fed
gonna manage this problem is are they
gonna keep Rising interest rates until
they can suffocate the consumers
and then they have no choice
don't know it's definitely very tricks
here now in nine days we have the fomc
interest rate Division and a press
conference so
that's what I've told you guys the next
10 days is going to be very difficult to
trade so make sure to apply proper risk
management stop loss
maybe they take less straights don't
over trade because
this is the type of environment where
you want to be losing money is quite
choppy at the moment okay you know you
can see now in the last level of three
ways bitcoin price been coming up coming
back down up down up down and it's in a
Range it's choppy but anyway let's go to
the charts and see what Bitcoin is up to
as you can see Bitcoin hasn't done much
in the last 24 hours is still in this
range which is the weekend rain so
they are waiting for news announcements
okay they were more they are waiting now
because after the market closes today
we're gonna have the earnings from
Microsoft and Google
but remember it's gonna be after the SMP
market is closed
but Bitcoin is not close so Bitcoin is
gonna be able to react to it
so what we are anticipating is after the
market closes later today
there might be some volatility coming in
crypto and tomorrow in the stocks but
Bitcoin did something quite interesting
yesterday though remember that we were
saying that we were still in the weekend
range we had to Advance Auto liquidity
pool we're gonna go in a minute to the
high block and then to the opposite in
the one hour time frame sorry in the one
hour time frame
we had a wig that needs to be filled
that one okay
and Bitcoin you can see that yesterday
what they did is that they went and hunt
all those liquidations
all the way to the 26900 zone and then
bounced and if we go to the Daily time
frame
we can see that yesterday candle closed
above the daily 50ma and right now
currently water still above it so
I can't be very very serious because we
are above support are you gonna short
above support
I'm not but it's also not an area where
you can long very confident because if
we go to the one hour time frame we can
see that the 50 EMA is acting as a
resistance and we can't get above it and
when we went above it in this Zone here
we were now able to test the 50mes
support because this week's is not a
darnold test in the 50 image you can see
they didn't touch it and then when we
want to touch it we as well again
so
I can't long here because we're above
sorry because we are below
low time frame resistance
and I can short
because we are above high time frame
support so while I'm waiting here is
to see Bitcoin bouncing
and then retracing the 50ma and then
this is the moment where I can log okay
that this is a support and then it can
long and it and I'll Target this area
the weeks or in the other scenario if
you go to the Daily time frame I would
have to see something similar but in the
opposite way I would have to see a
candle
closing below the 50ma then I want to
see a retest
happens and we lose the daily 50ma I
can't favor shorts
okay so what I'm gonna be doing is
basically what I said I'm gonna be
waiting in the one hour time frame and
see if Bitcoin can get above the daily
50 the 1 hour 50ma sorry retest the
support and then that's what I'll go
along to the 50 of the week
let's check the liquidation hit them up
in the one month time frame let's see
how this liquidations around you can see
they are gone they are liquidated
it's a sad story but it's a sad game and
you can see how these two yellow bars
are 27 026 900 diff disappear now
and that's because some Traders got
liquidated guys that's what you must pay
attention to where the liquidity is okay
because you don't want to be that
liquidity and you can see that the
market intentionally spiked down
to Liquidators Traders okay those
positions now let's go to the seven days
time frame
I suppose that it's gonna be quite a
messy chart at the moment because we're
in a Range it's quite choppy
let's see if it loads
here we are
I mean yeah as you can see that we are
right between two big liquid liquidity
zones 28 350 to the upside
and 26 350 to the downside
and this is basically because when price
is spiking up in a Range the retail
Trader is programmed to think that when
prices going up it's gonna go higher so
here they're gonna open more longs
and in this Zone when price spikes down
that's what I think the opposite the one
I think that price is gonna break this
Zone and go lower
so the liquidations are going to
increase in both areas this only shows
that the market is being very choppy at
the moment it's very difficult to get
right now
um a good trade for some hours so I
would say wait for confirmation keep an
eye on that
50 EMA in there one hour time frame if
you want to open longs
okay if you want to open shorts keep an
eye on the 50 I mean the daily time
frame
and play your trades accordingly
now you might be wondering what's the
target if we break below the daily 50ma
well let's go to the Daily time frame
I'm gonna tell you my opinion
and
if we break below this purple line and
the candle closes below it and test it
back as a resistance then price is gonna
go lower all the way here to 25 200 why
because it's a Zone where there has been
two sell-offs okay so it was a big
resistance at the time so you can see
here price goes up
there's a sell-off price goes up there
is a lot and this Zone has been tested
at support yet so
eventually
if price goes lower and breaks below
this Zone then the next Target is going
to be 25 200. what I don't like here is
that most Traders I'm saying are calling
for this target here above support
let's see what happens okay because you
know the theory of the contrary opinion
when people are bullish prices usually
goes low goes lower
and when people are the batteries like
now price usually bounces okay so be
patient let's see what the market gives
us and then we're gonna play with that
let's check really quickly how the
dollar Index and the SMP is doing
because you had some projections going
on there
oh I see just but it's bouncing now okay
that's interesting because you can see
that in this Zone
that is quite an important resistance
and there were a lot of spikes to this
Zone you can see all it's all weeks so
basically I think that they were
building their shorts price goes low
and now it's bouncing again and what do
you think is going to happen now well
I'm gonna tell you what I believe I
think the retail traditional thing that
this zone is a resistance so price is
going to do exactly the same it's gonna
come here okay rejected and go down but
what I believe is that price is probably
most likely gonna go higher because
there is a lot of liquidity here imagine
all the stop losses that are placed in
this song so I think the dollar Index
the most probable scenario is that it
keeps going high
I'm breaks above this song now if you go
to the SMP
sorry a SXP
here okay if we go to this oh it's going
to the Box finally
so you can see very clearly again we
were saying this that 4100 it was going
to be our next Target twice was playing
around this box with this weeks you can
see
okay
but eventually again people think this
is gonna be support
so price goes lower hit or lose
liquidations and stop losses and I think
I want to be in this box for some time
but
I remember that I said this in one of
the most recent videos
I don't want to delete that box let me
remove this manually
okay
if price but I think price here it's
basically
consolidating and is doing a sideways
move after a leg up okay so this is to
me sideways now if we break below the
4100 if we break below this box then
we're gonna have a big problem because I
think that most likely is the price
comes again to the 4 000 Zone okay so
that would be
around here so that's gonna that would
be a massive drop because
that is look for example here already
can't see that there is a zone that
should be
filled at some point as the 4020 so what
I mean with this is that this one needs
to hold
otherwise price is going to go lower and
Bitcoin should in theory follow
so keep an eye on this chart guys this
is pretty much everything I wanted to
say today I hope that you liked the
video and I see you soon